here with Roxy and John right now a lot
of people have been asking uh where's
Tara been a we wanted to say Tara we are
thinking about you and we want you to
heal up faster a lot of people don't
know it but it would I think would be a
great present to her right now since I
know Tara this well is if you could
follow her on social media do you guys
follow her on social media obviously are
you kidding me follow her on social
media guys we really want to do this
right now she's dealing with a case of
long Co well she said she can't
technically call it long Co yet until
the 3 month Mark but she has really bad
residual effects from the co and it's
keeping her from working which stinks
it's just like the absolute worst to
watch her go through I hope she purges
all of the uh covid symptoms my Purge
momy yeah so guys if you can go follow
her on social media and show her some
love I really feel like that'd be really
important we just wanted to give her
some well wishes right now send hearts
love you Tara he said nothing John